[Music]
good morning
he can't ignore the court that's the
view of the lawyer for the woman taking
prince andrew to court over allegations
of sexual assault we've spoken to him
about that lawsuit prince andrew has
repeatedly denied all of the allegations
against him while mr frey's lawyer has
accused the prince and his legal team of
stonewalling
the documents allege that prince
andrew's actions described above
constitute extreme and outrageous
conduct that shocks the conscience
prince andrew's sexual abuse of a child
who he knew was a sex trafficking victim
and when he was approximately 40 years
old goes beyond all possible bounds of
decency and is intolerable in a
civilized community
our correspondent spoke with virginia
dufrese legal counsel david boyce
how convinced are you that you will
finally get prince andrew to to speak in
in the manner in which you want him to
to answer those questions prince andrew
is going to have to now
speak
he can't ignore
court process
he can ignore me he can ignore my client
he can ignore other
victims
and their lawyers but he can't ignore
the court
the court process now is going to compel
him um if he were to
try to ignore the court the ways ignored
us
um
there would be a default judgment
entered against him we've reached out to
prince andrew's legal team
a number of times over the last five
years
we've made an attempt to
engage with him
to give him an opportunity to tell his
side of the story
to
provide any explanation or context that
he might have for his actions
to try to resolve this
without the necessity of litigation
every uh such effort has been rebuffed
they have totally stonewalled uh us just
like they've stonewalled the criminal
prosecutors in
in
the united states
so what happens next we're going to be
talking about that throughout the course
of the programme for you this morning we
believe the uh prince along with his
ex-wife is now holidaying with his
mother
interesting conversation i'm sure the
metro has a picture of prince andrew and
says the development is enough to make a
duke
sweat a reference to the defense prince
andrew gave during one interview there
he is photographed yesterday downfall of
the duke asks the daily mail it says
prince andrews stays silent after mr
frey's civil case was filed
in new york
to algeria now where wildfires are
burning 42 people have been killed by
wildfires in algeria it included 25
soldiers who were helping fight the
blaze the president of algeria described
them as martyrs who had helped save a
hundred people
[Music]
but we are fighting it with all that we
have and may god help
we are putting out the fire we are doing
all that we can may god help us to stop
it
well still to come on the program before
you half past seven we'll ask the shadow
minister for the armed forces at stephen
morgan how the government should handle
the hunger strike by former gurkha
soldiers
australia is about to introduce some of
the world's strictest travel laws and
lockdown restrictions we'll talk to one
nhs doctor who fears he might not be
allowed to leave and come back to
britain that's a 20 past eight
[Music]
and the world's best known footballer
leonel
messi i'm just just wondering whether he
is the world's best [ __ ] anyway
that's what we're saying this morning
lionel messi has uh completed a
multi-million pound move to paris
saint-germain uh we'll discuss the deal
with former england and liverpool
footballer john barnes and that is at 8
40.
[Music]
is it messy or is it ronaldo
you've probably got a view on that
haven't you can tweet me directly if you
would like to at k burley uh meantime
let's tell you about that group of
gurkhas who are continuing their hunger
strike on the streets of westminster in
protest against their military pensions
they're campaigning against receiving a
lower payment than soldiers from the
rest of the army here's what a
spokesperson for the ministry of defense
has told us
we greatly value the huge contribution
gurkhas make to the british army and
ensure they are supported with a
generous pension and medical care during
retirement in nepal we are committed to
ensuring the gurkha pension scheme is
sustainable and fair alongside other uk
public sector pensions
well yesterday we heard from the gurkhas
as well as the education secretary and
the former defense secretary gavin
williamson
as a former veteran himself i know that
ben puts an enormous value on this which
was an enormous value in terms of uh
gurkha regiment that's why it's been you
know
expanded and grown in uh recent years
because we we recognize their sort of
unfailing loyalty their failing
commitment we are fighting for equal
rights
if there is equal we will not fight
there is if there is no
discrimination we will not fight
pay pension family permission everything
that is the discrimination that is
against the human right
well our correspondent walker is outside
the protest at westminster and she is
with us now do you mind a very good
morning
to you this is what day
seven
day day five so the gurkhas have spent
four nights outside here this is the
fifth day of their hunger strike
and as you can imagine they are feeling
quite weary two of the women here have
received some medical assistance
overnight but considering that they
haven't eaten for this is the fifth day
now they are in remarkably good spirits
i would say i had a quick chat with some
of them this morning i'll move out of
the way a little bit okay so you can see
what is going on
so just to remind you the gurkhas who we
were speaking about this morning were
tied before 1997 and essentially their
pension scheme was calculated based on
the assumption their return to nepal in
2009 they were allowed to settle in the
uk they say their pensions have not met
um
you know the equivalent that their
british council counterparts get paid
and that is what they are fighting for
they say they have served in the british
army and they deserve equal pensions
yeah and we can um
actually
yes sorry i'll just remind you of what
um
yes who you spoke to yesterday and i
think you're going to speak to him a
little bit later today so they want
equal rights but the governments say
they do completely appreciate the work
that the gurkhas have done and they make
sure that they get paid a fair pension
indeed so and just um talk to me about
what happened uh yesterday um jemima
because they did have some sort of
flimsy tents to uh protect them from the
inclement weather didn't they but the
police have said that that needs to go
yeah that's right there were some sort
of gazebos put up here where the gurkhas
have positioned themselves the police
said that there is bylaw which means
that gazebos for example aren't allowed
last night they had some umbrellas up
they said they were asked to put them
down as well so they are fighting
against the weather and they are you
know that they're really trying their
best to stay here to keep warm to keep
safe but as i say this is day five of
them not eating they've spent four
nights outside but you know we will
hopefully be hearing more from the
government in the coming weeks on this
yeah i think the confusion with the
number of days they've been on hunger
strike jumbo is because they had started
it on a different day to start with and
it was a rollover hunger strike so not
everybody was on strike at the same time
but now these gentlemen that are there
have said that they're not going to eat
at all if they're there
until they either get what they want or
or they perish is that right
exactly that that is what they are
saying they say that they told you
yesterday on the show i think okay that
they are willing to stay here and
continue striking they continue the
hunger strike to death so this is not
for them ending until they see what they
view as equal pay okay jemima for now
thanks very much indeed thanks a lot and
it's literally across the road from
darling street we did approach the
ministry of defence for an interview on
the gurkhas yesterday but we're told
that they won't be able to facilitate an
interview with a minister
now a cardiff man who had to bury his
unvaccinated mother father and brother
after they died with coveted 19 says
it's absolutely vital people get their
jab against the virus francis gonzalez
has just returned to wales after flying
out to portugal where his family
relocated to a few years ago he says his
family had been misled by anti-vax
propaganda on the internet he spoke to
our correspondent dan whitehead
didn't expect to lose
one let alone or all three
you always think at least one will get
through
francis consalvas has just had to bury
his mother
father
and brother
they were unvaccinated
and all died with covid19
in the space of one week last month
his four-year-old brother shawl
was the first to pass
his heart failed in the ambulance on the
way to the hospital
it's i can't even explain the feeling
um
after that i just honestly i felt like i
was the one that was dead
three days later his father basil died
francis managed to land in portugal
as his mother was rushed to hospital
when they eventually took me through
they clouded me up in ppe
took me through to the ward and
um
i realized
she was in a far worse state that they
were letting me know
and then at about quarter to eight i
received the phone call
there is nothing that can ever prepare
you for that
the funeral process was difficult
um
particularly when you're signing off for
three coffins
three sets of flower arrangements
and
you see that all coming down in three
different horses when you're at the
cemetery
francis says his family were against the
vaccine and had been misled by
conspiracies online
they were afraid they they had a lot of
um information that had been passed
through the internet and you can call it
misinformation i think it doesn't
disinformation is probably more
appropriate
it's deliberately misleading people to
the point of it being propaganda and
if you don't trust the government if you
don't trust what you see on tv or social
media go to your doctor because they
will give you the best information you
have
in your mind how vital is it to have the
vaccine absolutely vital
if
they all had the vaccine i do believe i
would have at least one of them here
with me today
his unimaginable loss
a reminder that this virus is still
present
the memories
make it easier
because there were the good times there
were the happy times
you do miss those times
and there should have been more of them
dan whitehead sky news
in cardiff
meanwhile facebook has removed hundreds
of accounts it says were involved in
anti-vax disinformation campaigns
the firm claims the accounts were
operated from somewhere in russia in a
statement facebook said the pages were
aiming to recruit influencers to spread
false claims on covert 19 vaccines
especially those produced by pfizer and
astrazeneca
one of the uk's most senior scientists
has cast doubt on the need for everyone
to be given a covet vaccine booster the
health secretary has said the government
is drawing up plans for extra shots
from probably next month but professor
andrew pollard who helped develop the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine told mps that
booster jabs shouldn't be necessary
at this moment those doses that are
available that could be used for
boosting or for childhood programs are
much better deployed for people who will
die
over the next six months rather than
that very
unlikely scenario of a sudden collapse
in the programmes in countries that are
highly vaccinated
we'll be talking about that with a gp
later on in the program before you
looking at the figures another 32
250 first vaccine doses given uh
yesterday while another 137
000 people received their second
almost 40 million people are now fully
vaccinated that's more than three
quarters of all adults in the uk
there have been a further 23 500 new
cases 2 000 fewer than monday a further
146 people have sadly died that takes
the total number of people who've died
within 28 days of a positive test to a
hundred and thirty thousand
five hundred and
three
all vaccines are continuing to weaken
the link between cases hospitalizations
and deaths the proportion of infected
people admitted to hospital has now
roughly halved compared to the same
point in the second wave and deaths
relative to cases are now around nine
times lower
the nationwide infection rate now stands
at
277 cases per 100 000 virtually
unchanged from a week ago
lincoln has the highest rate in the uk
at 648 cases per hundred thousand the
lowest figures on mainland britain can
be found in carradigan in wales with 77
cases per 100 000.
and australia has introduced a ban
stopping almost everyone including
foreigners from leaving the country the
country's two largest cities sydney and
melbourne have been in lockdown as the
number of new cases of covid19 continues
to rise well sky news australia reporter
danica di giorgio joins us now from
sydney hello to you thanks uh for taking
the time to join us this morning so the
government is saying people can't leave
the country
yeah it's extraordinary new rules that
have come into force from today
essentially any australian who is based
overseas and comes to australia even
just for a visit well they now need to
be granted permission to leave now
ordinarily if you were leaving to go
back overseas you'd simply just have to
show your passport at the airport and
off you go but it's now designed to
close a loophole to stop australians
based overseas from coming back for a
visit particularly given in the last few
months the international arrivals cap
has been halved due to delta outbreak
strains like we're currently seeing in
parts of sydney but also to reduce
pressure on the hotel quarantine system
it's taken many by surprise some
australians based overseas have told sky
news they don't even know whether or not
they'll be able to return to the country
that they live in is it legal yes it is
nobody can challenge the health
minister's direction and even under
international laws australia doesn't
have a bill of rights meaning that no
citizen can actually challenge this
decision wow uh fascinating stuff thanks
very much indeed thanks a lot for
joining us on the program this morning
we will be uh speaking to an nhs doctor
who went down to australia to see family
can he not come back home no
we'll talk about that with him later on
in the show meantime hundreds of
buildings have now been destroyed by the
largest wildfire in california's history
the dixie fire has destroyed around half
a million acres of land as it's been
burning for nearly a month in the
state's northern forest lands
sky's mark stone has the latest for us
from taylorsville which is in california
we'll have a look at this such a visual
example of just how fast this fire can
move we're on the diamond mountain road
just outside the town of taylorsville
here in northern california this fire
has been burning on so many fronts for
so long and just
yesterday afternoon we were here and
this building was completely intact it's
someone's home
there was no sense that it was in any
immediate danger behind the building you
can see the trees there and behind that
maybe a kilometer or so um the uh the
hillside sweeps up and it's quite a
steep mountain and that's where the fire
was yesterday we could see the
firefighters trying to control it both
on the ground they were up as close as
they can get and it's very dangerous
work these are not small flames they're
flames that that lick the side of these
very very tall
pine trees so it's hard for them to get
close they were also trying to fight the
fires using helicopters as well
something they can't do now because the
visibility
is so low and yet overnight um they
managed they didn't manage to be able to
contain it and it swept down into the
valley here and took out that home and
also a barn of hay barn that was um that
you can see
just there so very very difficult work
and some of the numbers are really
striking this is a fire that's now been
going for for nearly a month uh that's
how long they have been trying to fight
it it's only 25
contained we're talking about half a
million acres of land that is or has
been burnt as the fire has progressed
and another figure that i think is
really striking uh is the the the the
span of the wildfire season which at the
moment is about 70 plus days longer than
it was just a few years ago so there's
no question uh even among locals here
some of whom might deny or or question
climate change as a human phenomenon but
certainly they do believe the climate is
changing the weather the summers are
getting hotter the winters are less cold
and there are other questions too local
questions just about how the forest
is managed and about clearing the forest
management and we'll leave you with the
image you can see there
these familiar
green fire engines that are sweeping
around the country this country as they
try to continue to put these fires out
and of course mark will continue to
monitor events for us there meantime we
want to return to our top story now
staying in america actually the lawsuit
filed against prince andrew joining us
is author of conversations with the
prince angela levin hello to
angela it's good to see you this morning
thanks for joining us um we believe that
andrew and fergie have gone to spend
some time with her majesty one wonders
what sort of discussions will be being
had behind closed doors
i think it's a very difficult situation
isn't it i mean
fergie will be very very pro and
upbeat and of course delighted that
she's been invited to stay in balmoral
for the first time in many many years it
was the late duke of edinburgh i
couldn't stand her around so she has not
been there so that's some
a big change this year i think the queen
will
listen very carefully and not say too
much at this stage because she's very
cautious about things and i don't think
she will
jump in and say what she wants to say um
i think that they'll wait until they've
had um advice from the lawyers
where lawyers are very good very
thorough and i think there won't be any
comment until they've actually got that
but it will spoil it for her i'm quite
sure because andrew is her favorite
child and this is her first time without
her husband of over 70 years so um
it should have been a sort of occasion
where the family are together and
positive and this will be hanging over
like a dark cloud i suspect yeah
apparently um he's taking the dog up
there as well in a different vehicle so
he's obviously planning to stay there
for a while but he does only have
something like 21 days i believe to
answer these allegations that have been
laid down in
the new york court allegations that he
denies
yes it's 21 days so he has to say
something
he's put off saying
things for a long time and um if he
doesn't they can actually come to a
decision about the the allegations and i
don't think that anybody would want that
so they have to make a very
uh
quick thorough job to decide how to
manage this there is of course several
ways which lawyers know which i don't of
of pushing back
wall places with all sorts of comments
and questions
and um statements so that it can linger
for a long time
days are very very important
yeah but you know it's 21 days that they
have been preparing for for a very long
time to the extent where prince andrew
has already stepped back from public
duties hasn't he
sorry i didn't quite hear that there's a
lot of voices in the background oh i'm
so sorry okay oh okay i will say it
again i'm so sorry angela the point i
was making was that he does only have 21
days now to reply uh by his lawyers
presumably but he has had several years
when he's known the allegations against
him to the extent that he's already
stepped back from public life
yeah so i think that the queen actually
and prince charles and
prince william
did take away all his um charities from
him because they feared that this could
happen
in the end and so he's really a bit like
a prisoner in a gilded cage at the
moment
and he did try to come back after
the duke of edinburgh's death he did
give a
talk to the press and was very fulsome
and i thought it was alleged to me that
he was trying to carve his way back but
that's absolutely not possible they
can't have that under any circumstances
so um nor can he really go out the
country because wherever he lands the
fbi could come along and and take him to
new york so his love of golf
particularly in america uh has to um
stay uh quiet for a while be curtailed
at least for now as we say just um for
the lawyer's benefit he of course uh
does um say that all of these uh charges
allegations against him are completely
false while i've just got you there i
wondered if i wanted i could move on to
a different subject which you will also
know much about angela given that you
are totally tuned into everything that's
happening with the royals harry and
megan they were absent from
barack obama's 60th birthday party there
were bezies before what's happened
well i think that's a very significant
but they were not only
kept out of the 70 that
obama had to have because of the kovi
problem but he'd actually invited 600
originally and they weren't there um
my own feeling is that they are more
wary of the couple and we know that they
both
love the queen they love the royal
family and i think that they feel that
family comes first and you can have a
big row you can actually let off a bit
of steam but i don't think you go on and
on and on criticizing the british
monarchy criticizing a 95 year old
grandmother who's actually the queen and
one of the most respected women
all around the world
and and your father and your brother um
i think that they're wary
and
have stepped back
i don't think they'll desert harry
because
obama really really likes him he
played a great
joking game in 2016 with the queen
over invictus games pretending they were
furious that england could win and
england was furious that america could
win and it was a wonderful little
video
and and he's felt very sorry for harry
and very caring about him and michelle
too
um but she did say that uh at the very
beginning um when they had she and megan
had a talk that
women have to
understand when they marry somebody
who's very well known in a very strong
position that they can't have it all as
it happens you have to step back perhaps
on your career and not try and do
everything at once and then later on you
can come back and get it
going up and running again and i think
she must be
quite shocked
at how they are behaving okay
fascinating stuff angela as always i'm
sure we'll speak to you again over the
next three weeks uh it's good to talk to
you this morning thank you
thank you
let me tell you about a group of men
claiming to represent mexico's most
powerful drug cartel they've threatened
to kill one of the country's best-known
television presenters goodness uh the
gangsters say that millennial television
network was favoring groups that are
battling the cartel
what about this
alpaca cam live
yep geronimo is to have a camera fitted
in his pen he doesn't please about it
does he so supporters can keep a
constant watch on his safety according
to the sun newspaper the owner helen
mcdonald on this show just yesterday
says she wants people to be able to
watch geronimo 24 7. he'll have a
million eyes on him all day
every day is what she says the animal is
due to be put down by defra after
testing positive twice for bovine tb
one of the world's best footballers
lionel messi has completed his move to
paris saint-germain
[Applause]
until now the 24 year old had spent his
entire career at spanish side barcelona
he's reported to have signed a two-year
deal worth 25 million pounds per year
after tax plus bonuses which is nice the
former england and liverpool legend john
barnes will discuss that multi-million
pound deal with us at 8 40 this morning
now live music is back after the
pandemic it seems and i can tell you
that one of britain's biggest
selling pop stars is going back on stage
ed sheeran has announced that he will
play what he's calling an intimate gig
next month at the shepherds bush empire
his first uk event since 2019.
uh if you go onto his instagram feed
because i already have it shows you how
you can register to potentially get
those tickets meantime the other arena
in london held its first full capacity
event since the lockdown began last
night
damon albarn's guerrillas performed to a
crowd of around 20 000. the audience was
mainly nhs workers and their family as a
special thank you concert
now then what's happening as far
hopefully we'll be able to listen to a
little bit of ed sheeran later on in the
programme but what about the weather
let's listen to nas now good morning nas
good morning well after mostly fine day
yesterday it's the return of rain once
again for some areas today so let's take
a look at the details
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so after a mostly fine and
largely dry day across much of the uk
and island yesterday today sees the
return of rain from the northwest again
in fact this morning there are spells of
rain with some pretty heavy downpours
across parts of ireland northern ireland
edging into western parts of scotland
it's also
rather gray start to the day across
northern and western parts of england
and wales with some patchy light rain
and drizzle across these areas whereas
further south and east of england and
eastern parts of scotland some central
areas of scotland too it's a mainly dry
and sunny morning but not for long
because that band of rain will be
spending its way eastwards with blustery
conditions and still some heavy
downpours across most of scotland this
afternoon to northern and western parts
of england and wales the rainbow patchy
enlightened nature and perhaps becoming
cloudy with some patchy light rain
across parts of the midlands
particularly the west midlands
in turn it becomes dry and brighter by
around midday across ireland northern
ireland then later western parts of
scotland will brighten up in fact
eventually that rain with some heavy
downpours will become confined to the
north and east of scotland and most that
rain becoming lighter in patchy nature
across the northern and western parts of
england and wales for central southern
and eastern parts of england fine for
today we continue with the sunny weather
particularly down towards the southeast
where the highest temperatures are
likely it will be feeling warm
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now just when the people of ireland
thought it was safe to go back into the
water this summer uh-oh wally the wall
ross
yep him again he was filmed driving a
speedboat well
sort of uh near conor kilsey in cork the
speed demon can clearly be seen going
from zero to
uh a hundred
about on his journey around the lake
without a care in the world in fact just
five days ago he caused disruption in
ardmore and people on the silly isles
built a pontoon to stop him causing
damage to boats there
completely nonplussed about it decided
to go to county cork instead who knows
where he might turn up next if you've
got pictures of him do please send them
to us here at sky news or you can tweet
me directly at k burley now let's get
more on that ongoing hunger strike
against army pensions by a group of
former gurkha soldiers this week we've
been asking cabinet ministers and shadow
ministers whether the current payment
system needs to change
i think that gurkhas are fantastic
soldiers who've had a unique
contribution to british history in that
military
and i think that it's very sad if they
feel that that that they've been treated
uh in this way i mean clearly you've
i've just heard of the story uh now
um and i'd like to look at something
we've had one of them on the program
point is do you think it should be
looked at surely everything 70 year olds
starving themselves to death of course
it should be i mean for them to have
come to a point where this is the
decision that they've taken and they
want to take this pursue this path of
course that should be looked at
as a former veteran himself i know that
ben puts an enormous value on this which
was an enormous value in terms of uh
gurkha regiment that's why it's been uh
you know expanded and grown in uh recent
years because we we recognize their sort
of unfailing loyalty their failing
commitment that's why we made changes to
the pension regime and pass and uh
that's why all these matters were always
kept on track
well let's speak to stephen morgan
shadow defense minister for the armed
forces um hello to you mr morgan thanks
for joining us on the programme this
morning um can you explain to us why
gurkhas are given a different pension
well good morning kane it's really good
to see you i'm really concerned about
this issue gurkhas as we've already
heard have served our country for 200
years and i think that they deserve the
most respect possible for their service
to our country they wear the flag on the
uniform for ceremony they wear their
flag in combat but i think it's
outrageous that the inequality continues
government promised two years ago to do
something about this five years ago they
promised to work with the government of
nepal to take action
and we've still not heard anything so
we're calling for action now by
government uh i think it's outrageous
that there are people on the streets of
number 10 that are sleeping
out there and not eating and we need to
take action
um so so what do you propose what what's
the opposition going to do
well the first thing we're doing is
actually listening and engaging and i
think ben wallace is looking out of his
window but not going out there to talk
to those that are on hunger strikes
that's the least a government can do but
we do need to see action i've had the
privilege of meeting some of our gurkhas
the royal gurkha rifles some time ago i
will be going to see them too but we do
need to see action on this issue i don't
know why their government are dragging
their hills but again this is another
example of the government talking the
talk but not walking the walk and
supporting our armed forces veterans and
their families
i'm not sure why gurkhas continue to
fall through the cracks i mean
ev when labour was uh in power uh you
failed to back them
as a as a party um and they eventually
did manage to get some increase in their
pensions they still want more what is it
about the go because why do they not get
the support that they should be getting
that they feel they should be getting
we were right to raise those issues but
k labour and government did deliver a
fairer pension scheme and we provide the
right for all gurkhas to settle in the
uk
but i mean i joined politics to fight
the injustice that those that served our
country and gurkhas that are doing this
protest right now should know that i'm
supporting them every step of the way
and we'll be writing to ben wallace
today to end this injustice
yeah um if they do
die on the streets of whitehall which
they say that they will unless they are
listened to
um what does that say about the british
state
i think that shows a huge stain on
society for all of us and i think the
government have got to listen ben
wallace needs to look out of his window
get down there the 10 meters that it is
and going sleeping and actually finally
once and for all
um we've heard that the government is
looking again at this issue and could
take further action in the coming weeks
what would
you support what would you like that to
look like
well we know pensions are a complex
issue and we need to work cross-party to
find a solution i've already spoken to
pete kyle who you spoke to yesterday and
i thank uk for raising these issues it
shouldn't be a party political issue yes
there are technicalities that need to be
addressed but the fact that the
government committed two years ago to
sort this and they still haven't done so
i think requires real action report to
parliament on the progress that they
made but ultimately the government
company to listen and engage with those
protesting mr morgan we have got a
letter from former defense minister
kevin jones um
uh this was in
2010 as we know
and the proposition that gurkhas of
earlier generations are less well
treated has been entirely rejected and
we will continue to honor and reward
their commitment and sacrifice through
the existing arrangement and it's not
the case that the equalization of the
pension would benefit the majority of
gurkhas so you know as i was pointing
out it is they are a group of people
that do seem to fall through the cracks
whoever's in power
i think you're right and i mean we're
now 11 years old since that quote was
made if i read uk an email that i've had
which has motivated me to help this
person said to me i've always viewed
britain as a fair and just society so
i'm shocked that gurkhas are treated so
poorly and felt as a national disgrace
that have been treated so badly and
they've resorted to risking their lives
by going on a hunger strike i mean i
think that should motivate all
parliamentarianitarians to take action
on this issue and rest assured i will do
so so where do we go from here mr morgan
well i'm going to be listening engaging
i'll be writing to ben wallace today
about the issues that have been raised
okay are you going to go down and see
the gurkhas
i plan to yes i've already been in
correspondence with them but will
continue to engage to the best of my
abilities okay it's good to talk to you
thanks for joining us on the programme
this morning thank you
tamara's here tomorrow we've been
talking about this um throughout the
course of the week haven't we it's not
going away for the government morning
kay no it isn't going away and i think
he hit on something uh important there
when you asked him about labour not
supporting the gurkhas in 2010 and the
key thing that's changed since then is
of course following that high-profile
campaign involving joanna lumley
thousands of gurkhas and their families
came and settled in the uk who'd retired
before 1997. their pension scheme was
suited to them retiring in nepal and the
government pointed out that they could
get it after 15 years service rather
than british veterans who had to wait a
lot longer so they believed that was
fair but now that many of those veterans
live in the uk many of them as we heard
on whitehall yesterday living on very
poor income some as little as 165 pounds
a month they told us from their pension
schemes they now believe that needs to
be revisited and clearly the government
think that as well because despite the
gurkhas losing a number of court cases
against the government over the years
two years ago the government gave them
an increase in their pension scheme in
recognition that this was an issue and
now they're consulting on making further
changes to that pension scheme so they
know that there is
an unfairness um that the gurkhas are
claiming the government do insist that
the scheme is fair but clearly they are
looking at some aspect of it whatever
the merits the optics are terrible if
there are people lying on the street
threatening to starve themselves to the
death within spitting distance of
parliament of the corridors of power and
and they're not going out to see them of
course that that is that is absolutely
right and this is this shows that some
of these people are in a really really
desperate situation financially they say
as a result of this pension scheme there
was actually a hunger strike by some
gurkhas back in 2012 and after it went
on for a few days the government did
engage with them and did start talking
to them and if this is to continue they
think they're now in their fifth day
only drinking water i would be surprised
if some officials didn't start to talk
to them at some stage okay tomorrow for
now thanks very much indeed more on that
with tomorrow's take just after nine
o'clock this morning
meantime let's take you to the united
states the most senior politician in new
york the governor andrew cuomo has
resigned following weeks of allegations
of sexual harassment an official
investigation last week concluded he had
groped kissed or made suggestive
comments to 11 separate women his former
executive assistant brittany comey so
waived her right to anonymity and spoke
publicly about what happened yesterday
as he announced his departure mr cuomo
gave this explanation of his behavior
in my mind
i've never crossed the line with anyone
but
i didn't realize the extent to which the
line has been redrawn
he
roped me
he touched me
not only once
but twice
and i don't think
that that had happened to any of the
other women
the touching
i respect the governor's decision and
i i respected sushi maine
lucky to have u.s political commentator
and journalist scotty nell hughes on the
programme with us this morning hello to
you scotty good to see you um last we
heard from joe biden there last week he
said
that he thought that the governor should
go was that his um death knell
well i don't know about that he go or
president biden wasn't the only democrat
but kay you just heard those sound bites
i mean that was one of the most cringy
apologies i think in resignation
speeches that in american history
and that was one of the things that
republicans or democrats probably agreed
upon most more than the infrastructure
bill that they passed yesterday that it
was time for governor cuomo to go
regardless of the 10 years of work that
even democrats tried to justify as being
good the last year had been nothing but
damage control for democrats trying to
figure out what exactly they were going
to do as more and more women up to
almost a dozen continued to come out
with these stories and they were all
saying the same things and the apology
yesterday okay that was far from an
apology it was almost like a
justification in his mind and for a man
who ten years in politics is supposed to
represent all the people of new york to
say that that line he did not realize it
was blurred it was insulting to not only
women but it was also
insulting to those of italian descent
saying this was just a part of the
culture there were so many things that i
think democrats realized yesterday was
wrong with this governor and his
perception of the people that i think
like i said i don't know who was
toasting or opening up the champagne
champagne bottles more to see governor
cuomo leave
donald trump or kamala harris because it
was definitely a nightmare for both
parties and having him in office how
damaging is it for the party though the
democratic party because we did see what
happened uh with uh donald trump when
the sexual allegations were made against
him that didn't ultimately seem to
damage either him personally or indeed
the republican party
well that was the one thing that was the
difference between donald trump and
governor cuomo in this case cuomo's
accusations were coming from his own
party from within and that was also on
top of all of the the studies and all of
the investigations going on right now
okay involving the nursing home scandals
and how he handled covet you know the
same thing that he got a five million
dollar book advance and it's got an emmy
award for he's we're actually coming to
find out that he made some very critical
um bad decisions that other governors
followed and putting people that were
positive for covet back into high risk
situation that investigation is ongoing
lots of other issues that are happening
on top of this so yes the democrats i
think they would be very happy to see
governor cuomo disappear into and fade
into the sun site but if republicans are
smart they will keep this as a reminder
to the general public as to what some of
the policies not necessarily the women
because i think across the board we can
all say that what he did to women was
wrong especially those within his office
but also the policies that he made that
those actually cause deaths here in the
united states cause deaths in new york
and considering he was the gold standard
as joe biden defined him last year
during the pandemic other governors
followed his rule and unfortunately
people died as a result
talk to me about whether i mean he's
only just gone but one wonders in the
fullness of time whether he might be
able to return he has a famous father of
course uh and an even more famous
brother
well i think actually the time for
governor cuomo is done and yes he did
offer apologies to his daughters but
there's obviously a lot of different
issues involved here and i think that
you realize that the reason why he
actually and he made this quite clear
during his apology resignation yesterday
it wasn't he wasn't apologizing for his
actions because he really did not see
much from worsening it he was
apologizing because he realized that his
party had left him and they were no
longer going to support him and that is
one thing that the democratic party does
once they're done with you just ask al
gore they're done with you and you fade
off into the sunset to write a book or
maybe have a netflix series but you will
never be seen from in politics again and
i think that is where the same fate will
be if you do not see a criminal
investigation or some sort of
prosecution actually go into governor
cuomo into both the actions from covet
but also with the with the 12 women in
their accusations scottie it's great to
see you thanks for staying up for us
always appreciate it
thanks a lot
uh now the environmental campaigner
greta tonberg has revealed that she
hasn't bought any new coal clothes for
at least three years goodness
the 18 year old was speaking after she
was photographed as the cover staff the
first ever edition of the magazine vogue
scandinavia she told them that the last
clothes she bought were actually
secondhand
which looks great and she warned that
mass-produced fashion at the moment was
not sustainable
he agrees
let's look at the impact of climate
change on the planet top line of our
dashboard have a look shows how the uk's
power is
produced and you can see how much warmer
the earth is now than in 1880 when
modern record keeping began that's the
second line then the figure to how long
scientists believe it will take to reach
the plus one and a half degrees celsius
figure seen by many as a point of no
return for the planet 11 years is what
they're predicting and finally a huge
and frightening statistic the total
amount of co2 emissions in millions of
tons
no despite intense campaigning a pla a
plane i should say has taken off for
jamaica deporting an unknown number of
people to the island protesters claim
many of them were brought up here since
they were children and regard britain as
their home well joining us now is karen
doyle founding member of movement for
justice which campaigns for immigrant
rights hello to you thanks for joining
us do you know who was on the plane at
this stage
over the course of the last two weeks
we've been talking to 30 detainees who
are at risk of being on the flight
of those 30 only four people were on the
plane so i only know those four people
there will be other people on the plane
who were not in touch with us
um who or who wanted to return accepted
a voluntary return
okay so how did we manage to reduce from
30 to just four
we intense campaigning as you said
but also the majority of those who had
their tickets cancelled had valid human
rights claims or other claims as to why
they should not be put on that flight
and one of the reasons we do campaign is
because by the very operation of these
flights they prevent people accessing um
legal advice and the justice that they
need to prove their cases
um combined with legal aid cuts people
have not been able to present the
needs of their children and the voices
of their children or expert
evidence that's needed to kind of prove
their case so it's been two weeks of
intensively making sure that everyone
has what they need
to um make their case
the government would say in response
that the people uh many of the people
that were what they wanted to be on this
airplane had committed a crime is it not
right for them to be asked to leave
it's a very simplistic way of looking at
human beings all of the people on the
plane have committed a crime all of them
have served time for that crime that a
judge thought was
just for that crime
many of them have been out of prison for
many years
not committing any further offenses a
whole number were for non-violent
offenses a number
well actually i'm happy to say all of
the people who came as children that we
were in touch with
were not on the plane
but there were people who were at risk
of being on the plane who had been
groomed into criminal activity from a
young age who'd been here since three
months old two years old five years old
who were more british than jamaican
and
so i don't
while the law says if you commit a crime
of 12 months or more you should be
deported
the reality is very different in terms
of the lives that people have and the
cases that people have
um talk to me if you would quickly about
what's going to happen to those 26
people that have been taken off the
airplane
they are for the most part are one that
i know of um they are still in the
detention center um for some of them it
they were taken off the plane because of
an injunction for others there was no
reason given they were just taken off
the plane um so
they are going to have to go through a
process of
um making their case in the courts and
um applying for bail to get out of
detention center